أعلن ملك المغرب محمد
الحداد الوطني لمدة ثلاثة أيام هنا في
مراكش وذلك لأن
بلاده دمرت بالكامل
بسبب زلزال غير عادي
غير متوقع على الإطلاق في مدن مثل مراكش، كان
هذا هو المشهد هنا في
المدينة المنورة، الجزء الأقدم من هذه
المدينة القديمة  من الواضح أن هذا المبنى قد
تمزق بسبب هذا الزلزال الذي
بلغت قوته 6.7 درجة على مقياس ريختر، لكن
المشاهد كانت أسوأ في المناطق
الداخلية من البلاد حيث تم
انتشال امرأة كانت محاصرة لمدة 12 ساعة
من تحت الأنقاض في قرية نائية
الآن هناك.  هناك 13 شخصًا لقوا حتفهم هنا في
مراكش في جميع أنحاء البلاد، وقد مات أكثر من
1300 شخص،
وتتوقع السلطات هنا أن ترتفع هذه الأرقام
ببعض السرعة،
لكن مشكلتهم تكمن في الخروج إلى المناطق
الأكثر تضرراً، حيث يقع مركز الزلزال على بعد
حوالي 45 ميلاً جنوب ولكن  المناطق
التي تعرضت لدمار شديد
وفقًا للسلطات المحلية هي
قرى تقع في سفوح
جبال الأطلس، وهي القرى التي
أظهرت الصور الجوية بالفعل أنها سويت بالأرض
بالكامل مع بقاء منزل
أو منزلين يبدوان كما لو
تم بناؤهما.  على الحصاة وتلك
الحصاة التي كانت أنقاضها في يوم من الأيام قرى
وتقع في تلك المناطق التي
تشعر السلطات فيها بالقلق الأكبر من ارتفاع أعداد
الضحايا من القتلى والجرحى
ولكن بالطبع المشكلة الأخرى
التي تواجه السلطات هي أن الوصول إلى
هذه المواقع أمر صعب حقًا  سيكون الأمر
صعبًا للغاية لأنهم
يقولون إن عددًا كبيرًا من الطرق
وشبكات الاتصالات قد تم قطعها
بسبب هذا الزلزال الذي لم يكن
متوقعًا على الإطلاق، ولا يمكن لأي من السكان المحليين الذين تحدثت إليهم
هنا في مراكش أن يتذكروا أي
تاريخ من الزلازل هنا في أي مكان آخر من
البلاد  نعم ولكن هنا يقولون أنهم لم
يختبروا أبدًا زلزالًا بلا ذيل، ولا يوجد
تاريخ يقولونه عن أي نوع من
الزلازل ولكن هذه هي النتيجة،
نعم، سجاد الفراش الذي ترك
معلقًا على حافة الجدران التي
تم تقطيعها تمامًا كما
فعلت هذه المدينة القديمة  تم إعادة بنائها على مدى
العقود القليلة الماضية، وقد تم بذل قدر هائل من الجهد
في إعادة إعمار
مدينة مراكش، خاصة هنا في
المدينة المنورة، وهي واحدة من فخر المغرب وهي
وجهة سياحية إلى حد كبير ولكنها أيضًا
موقع لأحد قصور الملك الرئيسية.
المركز الثقافي للعديد من المغاربة وهذا
ما فعله الزلزال الأخير
سام كايلي سي إن إن في مراكش